Now let's look at how to send
a message from sender to receiver together.
Now let's go to our sender blueprint actor.
The first thing for the sender
is that we will read our launch parameter,
as we just saw previously in our packaged build,
we use different batch files to set things like if it's
a sender or if it's a receiver,
and we will set things to react to different ports,
the sender IP and receiver IP, etc.
Let's click into the read launch parameter blueprint function.
I put it into a blueprint function library so we can easily reuse
that across different blueprint class.
So we see that I'm using
the same blueprint function in the sender one,
and also again in the receiver one.
So let's click into the event here,
the read launch parameter event.
So first thing, I'm just getting the command line and I'm
parsing the command line and check out the launch parameters.
This one is a really useful map,
is already classified into different types of launch parameter.
First, I will find if there is an OSC receiver launch parameter.
If it is, I want to set this one to be a receiver.
If it's a sender, it will return a Boolean to set it is
a sender and then I can set my receiver IP,
and I will also set my sender IP and this
is only useful when we want to do two-way communication.
The receiver can also send message back to the sender.
Finally, we will set the port we want to use for this communication.
Finally, we will check if we want it to be
a two-way communication or just a one direction communication.
So let's just go down the path.
So for the sender,
we already have a client targeting
the correct IP import and I save it as an OSC client.
Let's move down to see
some example and then we will build our own together.
So let's take this event for example.
This is for a sender to send out an integer message.
So first thing, we're going to create an empty OSC message.
We want to convert a string to an address,
add to it, we want to add an integer,
we want to send it.
I just have a print string so I can
also see from my side what is being sent.
So I can compare with the result just for a debug purpose.
Finally, I will clear the OSC messages as a good practice.
Make sure we have nothing overriding the later coming message.
So now let's build this one together and instead of
an integer let's say we want to send out a string value.
So first, I'll right-click and do Make OSC message,
and I want to set my address,
set OSC message address,
and from the address here,
I want to use it from a string.
Not this one. So I want something that converts a string to OSC address.
So the string I will use slash test slash string.
Okay. So now I have an OSC address,
I'll drag it into the address.
Now from the output here,
I'm going to add a string value.
I'll add string to OSC message.
I will do make literal string,
and actually just for fun,
I will add two string to it and we
can specify it when we receive them.
We're actually now on the second one,
I will add a integer to it,
and I want to send it to my client.
So I will do OSC client,
I will do send OSC message,
and the message I want to send is from this one,
the output of the last node.
Finally, I want to clear OSC message.
So we can actually just send it as is,
but because I want to continue to say we have
like a 100 different event I want to send and is
all the same structure of a string and then a integer.
So I'm just going to make it into
a custom event by right-click and type in custom,
and I want to name it send string integer.
I will connect the execute node,
and the first line,
I'll just make sure the value,
I'll say it's a string value,
and drag the integer here also into the input value.
I'll say this is a integer value.
So that's it. So we can then fire
this event somewhere to send
a OSC message with an address test slash string,
that will contain some kind of string value
and some kind of integer value here.
Now, that's actually it.
Now on the receiver side,
let's go to receiver.
On the receiver side, we already have
some example of receiving messages,
and so we see that first thing,
it would check if it is a receiver from
the same read launch parameter
blueprint function library.
First, if it is a receiver,
it will create an OSC server to start listening,
and the port we're also going to specify here,
it will save it as an OSC server,
and we see that it is
bind event to when there is a bundle received,
and when there is an OSC message received.
So let's click into the when
OSC message receives bundle event,
which will be this one.
Now, I'm saving the message I received as
a variable here and then I will read its address,
and I will convert the address to a string just so that we
can then do a switch on string to
decide different reaction I want it to happen.
So we already have set scale,
set color, and set hidden.
I am just going to add one more,
and we know that the address we set on
the sender is called slash test slash string.
I'm just going to copy and go to the receiver one,
and do this test string compile.
Now, we have one more execute node here.
So now, I just want to make a very simple print string
for a star to just make sure we have
the communication set up correctly.
I will do like this.
I will do get OSC message.
So we know that the first one we have is a string.
I will do string at index,
and the message we want to get is this one.
So the first one must be a string,
and then that's true.
Another one, we also know the second one is an integer.
So we drag it out and I'll say get OSC.
Actually, let's just do a right-click.
Get OSC message, integer at index,
and let's drag the message in again.
We know that the integer is the second one in order.
So the index here must be one.
Now, I want to do a print string,
and I want to append,
I'll say I received a string equals to this string,
and also the integer equals to this integer.
Just so we can see it easily,
I will expand it and I'll say I want it to be a 10 second,
and it's a yellow text.
So it's a little bit special.
So that's it. That's an example of how
to send and receive a string plus an integer.
That's actually super flexible.
You can imagine that we can use
the same structure we can continue to add on things,
like we can add not only integer,
we can continue to add on floats, booleans,
everything can be in one single OSC message,
and we have so many ways to utilize them.
Even more so if we know we will continue to use
a string plus an integer format over and over,
we can also bring this address into the input.
So we can even send
different address using this same custom event.
So now to quickly test if we are able to send and receive,
I will go ahead and actually disconnect,
or go past this part and just make sure it will create
a server and in the center side to do the same thing.
I will bypass this part to make sure it have the client,
and for the port here,
both are using number 0, I'll just continue to.
So now if I hit play in the editor,
the sender is going to create a client
targeting itself because the receiver is blank,
and this receiver is also going to
create a server that is listening to port 0.
So now if we hit play,
oops, I forgot one thing.
So that's open level blueprint,
and we have to make sure we are firing
this send string and integer event here.
Let's go to level blueprint,
and I want to drag my BP or C sender.
Let's say whenever I hit
K or actually X,
which is also a good power C. Whenever I press C,
I want to set a send string and integer event,
and I want the string to be I pressed C,
and the integer will be,
I'll say 100, and I'll add one more time,
and this time I want this to be not C,
but V, I'll say I pressed V,
and the integer will be,
I think 999.
Now if I hit play,
and if I press C, nothing happens.
So just know that the OSC port must be something not zero.
I'm going to just test it again.
I'm running, and I'm pressing C.
So that is working.
I press V, and it receives a different integer.
We can use the same way to check other OSC communication.
So now if I want to see,
I'm changing color,
and it said I received address,
set color, that is correct.
You can receive address,
set hidden, that is also correct.
You can also change scale.
Okay, read property, let's see.
Oh, yeah, that's because we bypassed some of the events here.
Now we test it in-game,
and the one-way communication is working.
Let's move on to the next part.
In the next part,
we're going to do enhance our exercise of setting a bundle.